welcome to the presentation on
multiplying expressions let's get
started
so if i were to ask you what
x
plus 2
times i'm using different color
times
x
plus 3 equals
at first you'll be like huh that's a
little uh strange but it turns out that
you actually already know how to do this
problem and it's just the distributive
property
because if i just had let me write a
different problem here if i just wrote
a and let me just make clear this is a
separate problem if i just wrote a
times
x plus 3
you know that that's just
a
x
plus
well plus you could say a 3
or another way to say that it would be
3a right but as you see all we did is
distribute it we could just write a
times 3. all we did is distribute the a
times the x and the 3. well we're going
to do the same thing here but instead of
a we have x plus 2. so let's do that so
this would be
let me switch to green
you get
x
plus two
now since i'm using green i'm just going
to stay with green
x plus 2. they switched to orange
x plus 2 times x
plus x plus 2 times
3.
does that make sense
if that looks a little confusing just
pretend like that x plus 2 is the a in
this example and all we did is we
distributed it across that x plus 3.
and now it becomes a pretty
straightforward problem what is
we we do distribution again with each
parts of this problem
so let me stay in orange
what is x times x well that's
x squared
and then x times two well that's two x
so we did this left hand side already
and now we do this right hand side
what's 3 times x well that's 3x
and what's 3 times 2 well that's 6.
and now we're almost done we could say
oh we have a 2x here and a 3x here we
can simplify and add those together
and we know that that equals x squared
2x plus 3x is equal to 5x x squared plus
5x
plus 6.
so all we did there's really nothing new
to learn here we just distributed the x
plus 2 times each term of x plus 3 and
we got the second step and then we
distributed this x times x plus 2 and
this 3 times x plus 2 and simplified
let's do a couple of problems and
hopefully
it'll hit the point home
let's say
i had
x plus 9
times
four x
minus two
well once again that equals
five x plus nine
i'm just distributing you know i want to
stay in my color that i'm using so
that's why i'm just writing it out like
this
that equals 5x plus 9 times 4x
and then plus 5x plus 9 times minus 2
right this minus 2 is here
and this 4x is here
and now we just multiply it out 5x times
4x
is 20
x squared
i hope that makes sense to you because
let me write down this corner 5x times
4x is the same thing as 5 times 4 times
x times x and that equals 20x squared
hopefully that makes sense to you
so going back to the problem 5x times 4x
is 20x squared plus
9 times 4x is 36
x
plus
minus 2 times 5 x
so that's minus 10 x
and then 9 times negative 2 well that's
minus 18. we're almost done
so we get 20x squared
and we have 36x
minus 10x so that's plus
26x
minus 18. there we're done
let's do another problem
let's do
x
plus y
whoops
so parenthesis
time i'll stay in one color now because
i think you understand what we're doing
times
three
x plus two y
well once again
this is the same thing as and we could
just do it a little different way a
little different order but we could
distribute it like this we could say
this is 3x
times 2x plus y
plus
2y
times 2 x plus y see what i did i just
switched the order this time just to mix
things up this 3x is there and this 2y
is here and we just distributed it along
2 and we just we mult we distributed the
2x plus y along each of these numbers
and now we just multiply it out 3x times
2x is 6
x squared
3x times
y
that's
xy right 3xy is just another way of
saying 3 times x times y
plus now 2 times y times
2y times 2x well that's 4
yx
for yx right 2 times 2 times y times x
plus
2y times y
well that's just 2 y squared
now can we simplify anything here
think about it a little bit
well it turns out that x y and yx are
the same thing they're just switching
the order so you can just rewrite this
as 6 x squared
plus
x y
plus 2 y squared and we could have just
as easily have written it as 6 x squared
plus seven
y x
plus two y squared
hope i'm not confusing you let's do one
more real fast and
let's
do 2x plus 2
squared ah
well
you might be tempted to just square each
of these terms but you got to be careful
because you have this x here so it
actually turns out that this is equal to
x plus two
times two x plus two right any number
squared is just that number times itself
so any expression like two x plus two
squared is just that expression times
itself
and now we can just do it as this is the
same thing as
2x
times 2x plus 2
plus 2 times 2x
plus 2. we just multiply everything out
2x times 2x
x squared
2x times 2 well that's 4x
plus
2 times 2x that's 4x again
and then 2 times 2 well that's 4.
and we're almost there
we just can add up these two terms this
is 4x squared
plus 8x
plus 4. and we're done
i think you're ready now to try some uh
level 1 multiplying expression problems
hope you have fun